"Tink, where are you?" Peter called quietly. "Did you find my shadow?"
The sound of golden bells answered him. It is the fairy language.
Peter quickly pulled his shadow from the drawer, but it would not stick back on!
He began to cry. His crying woke Wendy.
"Boy, why are you crying?"
Peter bowed to her, as the fairies had taught him.
"What's your name?" he asked.
"Wendy Moira Angela Darling," she replied.
"What is your name?"
"Peter Pan."
"Where do you live?"
"Second to the right," said Peter, "and then straight on till morning."
"What a funny address!"
"No, it isn't," he said.
"Is that what they put on the letters?"
"Don't get any letters," he said.
"But your mother gets letters?"
"Don't have a mother," he said.
"Oh Peter, no wonder you were crying," she said.
"I was crying because I can't get my shadow to stick back on."
"It has come off?"
"Yes."
"Then it must be sewn on," she said. "I'll sew it on for you."
She sewed the shadow onto his foot, and soon he was jumping around happily.